[Applaudissements]
c
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
nous
quand vous
[Musique]
mais ça
[Applaudissements]
côté du rhum je suis fan 5 et si riche
que ça à fond sur un mail de six mois je
le connais par coeur
alors jamais là elle a un nombre de
tubes comme mass hydra un truc et je
vais te dire comme je me suis rendu
compte en plus tu avais beaucoup plus de
tubes que je que le pas à ce qu'on dit
chaban en tête ce que c'est un truc de
ouf mais là ça fait ça fait dix ans
maintenant que 15 49 ans moi je t'enlève
cinq ans et pour moi c'est cadeau sache
que ja il ya quelqu'un qui travaille
également dans la musique c'est ton
frère ton cousin je crois que c'est
quelqu'un de ta famille il s'appelle
qu'amel bent et ce soir c'est notre
cadeau pour toi c'est parti qui fait
amel bent découvrez son cousin tunisien
qu'amel bent pour faire la promo de son
kebab il reprend tous ses plus grands
tubes à sa sauce avec ma philosophie
gêné qu'une sandwicherie tout droit
venus de tunisie
je ne fais jamais crédit pour moi aussi
il faut payer
si je n'ai pas moi rire
[Musique]
et si tu reviens brij lal
ne retient pas que les gens bon bah y'a
pas non plus bouder
nous mange pas que khallouf
on préfère les touffes fait tout ça fait
du bien
tiens dixon ou encore où je vais arriver
des coupes et assaisonner la grille
c'est dur d'entrée 2
tourné pour moi je ne sais pas
[Musique]
kamel ben prochainement en galas dans
tous les couscous de france
[Applaudissements]
je pense que dire télé-crochet rêve ou
désillusion c'est ça va plus loin que ça
c'est ce métier c'est pas exact pas
seulement les télé crochets c'est la
dure réalité de ce métier qui peut être
violent et et où tout peut basculer du
jour au lendemain et ça c'est le à
partir du moment où je veux juste être
la personne qui dit que quand tu choisi
ce métier
à un moment donné faut arrêter de te
plaindre mais il ya des moments et même
quand tu es passé professionnel et que
tu es connu et reconnu ben tu peux un
moment donné tu retrouves au fond du
trou bien sûr après c'est à toi tu as
décidé de vivre de ta passion c'est une
vie de troubadour et s'est pas fait que
pour passer tout le temps la télé gagner
plein d'argent ces thèmes chantés
magalie vaé on la voit pas la télé mais
qui vous dit qu'elle est en train de qui
fait sa vie et chanter partout et
elantra n'ai pas chanté lâché un avis on
doit il ya une vie en dehors tout ça
quand tu as choisi la musique un match
extrêmement extrêmement content et quand
elle est au td garden ah non mais quand
à dallas à l'audition de la nouvelle
star tu t'es dit moi je veux je veux
gagner je veux y aller mais craignent de
faire mon métier ou pas du tout mais par
hasard j'ai perdu ma voix moi au bout du
premier prêt mentalement j'étais choqué
de d'être la bête de passer une étape
j'étais à fond à nouvelle star
d'ailleurs est ce que vous vous rappelez
de votre casting
ah ouais c'était quoi la chance dans la
rue en fait il ya un truc que j'avais
pas compris et je trouve que c'est un
peu aussi le défaut de des premières des
premiers télé crochet c'est qu'on était
un peu mal encadré quand même on n'était
pas prévenu de ce qu'on allait vivre et
c'était hyper éprouvant mais c'est
génial je ne regrette pas d'y aller j'ai
adoré ça m'a lancé mais je m'en souviens
j'avais très très peur pour rappeler de
votre duo avec alicia keys
bah oui c'est énorme mais jamais une
tâche de frontin derrière la robe je
m'étais assis sur du fond de teint comme
ça une europe des leurs at elle pas
d'autres tenues maintenant rien ne
m'inquiétais pas ça c'est très bien je
ne veux pas me retourner j'ai peur juste
régine cash comme ça tout est un des
très grands moments la nouvelle star
pour moi vraiment regardé j'allais
perdre
[Musique]
et
idée
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avec elle c'est pas con c'est
exceptionnel